c'est le grand jour pour le festival de
cannes comme tous les ans le monde du
cinéma aura les yeux braqués sur la
croisette le coup d'envoi c'est ce soir
20 films en compétition et un jury
présidé cette année par isabelle huppert
sur place stéphanie perez et nathalie
berthier ce rôle là elle ne l'a pas
encore tenu madame la présidente prend
la pose dans un palace cannois le temps
de s'habituer à ses nouveaux habits ce
soir elle déclare a ouvert ce festival
qu'elle connaît par coeur
dix sept films en compétition en 30 ans
de carrière deux prix d'interprétation
féminine en 1978 pour violette nozière
ce très heureuse je remercie beaucoup
le jury et je remercie beaucoup
claude chabrol et en 2001 pour la
pianiste de michael haneke
un choix qui sonne comme une évidence et
face à ce monstre sacré edouard baer qui
jouera ce soir les maîtres de cérémonie
est dans ses petits souliers
elle a tourné avec comme idée metteur en
scène vue du monde entier elle est long
et de chi minh hoa chabrol c'est comme
les filmographies assez exemplaire c'est
un peu intimidant et pour moi pour ma
génération
elle aime le mystère alors à canal a
appris à composer avec les paillettes et
les petites vanités du tapis rouge si
elle n'a manqué quasiment aucun
rendez-vous cannois c'est par pure
passion pour son art qu'elle travaille
avec liberté cette science du jeu
qu'elle porte à son plus haut point je
n'ai pas de sentiments walter vous
feriez vous mettre ça dans la tête et
même si j'en ai à jour et ne
triompheront j'amène mon intelligence
c'est depuis ses premières apparitions
comme ici en 1976 elle affiche son
exigence mais est-ce que les à-côtés du
festival vous intéresse aussi se dire le
cinéma autour du cinéma
oui enfin un petit peu par et amusant
pour les comédies un an
c'est amusant pas petites doses par jour
comme vous avez en compétition parmi les
plus grands auteurs de l'époque
vous avez intérêt à leur mettre une
présidente un président ou une
présidente en l'occurrence des jurés qui
leur donneront le sentiment que leurs
films seront jugé qu ils concourront
pour un palmarès entouré de gens qui
savent ce que c'est que le cinéma ce
soir madame la présidente gravira les 24
marches du palais pour assister à la
projection du dernier né des studios
pixar à dessin animé en 3d
loin des films d'auteurs qui lui ont
fait emprunté des chemins de traverse
ça tombe bien cannes pour elle c'est la
porte ouverte à toutes les nouvelles
idées du monde